[Music]
oysters have an ancient history in the
waters of chesapeake bay
but due to over harvesting pollution and
disease more than 99 percent of the
historic native oyster population
has disappeared the state of maryland
has committed to a restoration plan
looking to rebuild
oyster colonies in five tributaries on
its side of the bay
skylar henry met up with the team
leading that effort along maryland's
eastern shore
as the sun rises over the little chop
tank river
there's a crew hard at work responding
to a crisis under water that's been
unfolding for centuries
the declining population of the native
chesapeake bay oyster
inside each of these 3 000 gallon tanks
are
millions of future oysters the work done
by non-profit
the oyster recovery partnership the work
that we're doing is
all in maryland at this point working in
tributaries within the bay to restore
those
those oyster reefs leading the
restoration effort
executive director ward slakem oysters
are important to the cultural heritage
of maryland for one oysters that being
the keystone species it means that
they're really critical
to not just the ecosystem of the bay but
all the other animals that reside in the
bay
but the harvest of those oysters also
contributes to the economy maryland's
seafood industry is responsible for
bringing in nearly 600 million dollars
annually
businesses like fadely seafood in
baltimore maryland
are directly dependent on the bay's
overall well-being but without the
oysters we don't have anything
we need that oyster to siphon and clean
the water in the chesapeake bay
damie hahn is the fourth generation
running fade lace
100 years ago our oyster population
could do it in 24 hours our
current oyster population takes nearly a
year
to do that same job that it could do in
24 hours
we can't do what we do in providing
fresh local without fresh local so the
health of the chesapeake bay
is is key to our success it's key to our
future
the bayley family has owned and operated
the market for more than 130 years
through the 1800s early 1900s
the oyster industry was really what
defined baltimore
a lot of areas would backfill with
oyster shells they used crushed oyster
shells
so we were using the shells
not realizing that they needed to go
back into the bay
it wasn't until the 1950s when
scientists discovered the link to the
bay's declining health
we were depleting our supply and that
these oysters needed old oyster shells
in order to grow new baby oysters this
bat
but with the shells shuck then the
oysters dressed
a little dab of a cocktail and a little
squeeze of lemon there was no easy way
to get the used shells back into the
water
cheers cheers here you go
fantastic they are they are so good so
good they're so good
now we have to recycle these shells
fadeley's is one of about 400
area seafood restaurants markets and
public job sites that has been recycling
their shells through the oyster recovery
partnership
orp crews pick up the shells and bring
them to the university of maryland's
horn point laboratory to be processed
over the next year
when we get the dirty shells they're
aged they're clean and then they're
loaded into the containers and then
placed into the tanks ready for us to
start
putting mature larvae in it stephanie
alexander is the laboratory's hatchery
manager
they filter the water they create
habitat they are also spawning and
adding to the population
and they're also helping with shoreline
stabilization as well as nutrients so
question
so overall they're extremely extremely
valuable they're the little kidneys of
the bay
but these vital organs of the chesapeake
need some assistance to repopulate
at the rate needed to keep the bait
clean so
what we have here is what we have a
bunch of oysters that we don't know the
sex of yet
getting ready to start their
reproduction around
25 thousand adult oysters a year are
rotated through these spawning tables
they're filtering this water in and they
are tasting it
to say hey somebody else is spawning i
need to start spawning a response and
it's 18 reactions
because they have to spawn at the same
time in order for fertilization to take
place
in about two weeks the fertilized eggs
will be mature enough to be drained from
their indoor incubators
gathered for their next stage in life
right now there's five million
larvae in my hand the bundle of larvae
will be set in one of the outdoor tanks
that's
filled with the recycled oyster shells
the goal
to get the larvae to attach to the
shells where they'll grow for life
a process known as spat on shell
after another week or so they're loaded
up onto a boat
and released into the water and then
when they're deployed
they go out there they're put in reefs
is that correct they're put on reefs
which is basically a hard substrate but
we don't want to put them in the mud
because if you put oysters in the mud
they're going to sink and they're going
to die and then all of our efforts for
nothing
orp says they've planted around 8.5
billion juvenile oysters back in the
waters and have rehabbed reefs and two
tributaries with three more to go
set to be completed by 2025. there's a
lot that goes into this funding wise as
well right
absolutely it's a it's definitely a
multi-million dollar
operation to restore oysters annually
in maryland and there's a huge
commitment from the state of maryland to
provide that funding
noaa also provides funds and so does the
u.s army corps of engineers
but manmade challenges are once again
risking the oyster survival
historically over-harvesting and disease
issues were kind of the big driver of
the decline of
oysters now i think it's lack of
suitable substrate
because as the land becomes developed
you have more runoff and in that runoff
you have more sediment and that sediment
is falling out and burying the
oyster reefs shell is very limiting so
we need everything we can get
so there's little steps that everybody
can get involved in you can eat oysters
you can support oyster aquaculture farms
and just make it a big circle of oyster
love
for cbs this morning saturday skyler
henry
cambridge maryland a big circle of
oyster love and the little kidneys in
the bay
i had no idea how important
yeah well it just goes to show you how
sustainability it should be a part of
our practice
as human beings and yet we we thwart it
in so many ways take care of the oysters
they take care of the ocean they take
care of our bellies
yeah that too right i mean it's all it
all works together if you're doing it
the right way
really really great insight and great
program